我们聊聊到底该怎么赚钱的方法吧
普通人
最靠普最简单
最不可能遭受反事
最持实久的方法
就是给他人提用价值
停起来像其他
但是我们是有具体的实抬的落影方法的
老规矩
想到哪儿说哪
我在价值新法里曾经当年说过
我们一定要练习那种发现问题
几个问题的能力
就别人在生活中一道问题了
你能帮他解决
你就能赚到钱
那很认识我啥也不会
别说给别人解决问题的我
我自己要解决不了问题
你会
你这二十年
三十十年
四十年五十年
五十百国的
就很多人
你看他在后面
他来到这个世界才多长时间
对不对
还有很多人
他一定会经过你
你觉得这个东西很彩很简单
但是他也一定会那条路
他该走的都来走
不有那句话吗
就天下没有白走的
我们给过都算说
没有一条路是白走的
你又想一想
你当初
是怎么被卡住的
有哪些东西可以帮助别人
对吧
我之前给大家讲过一个方法
你们就查
叫派给两年前的自己
那那时候我真的就啥也不会
那请你记住这句话
你可以会
没有人天生什么都会的
我有说一下
那说大师因为你我粉丝
我天生就我粉丝
你看看
我是问
天中期材
那是因为你口才行
我天生就口才行
那是你会变成我天生就会变成
记住一句话
你可以会
只要你可以
会发现问题
解决问题
就能转到钱
很多人的原因
那两个
第一个是
自己把自己吓退的
天生给自己安排八个
我不会
我是个笨蛋
我又复了气了
还有自己给自己
咱们填标一下
对吧
第二个就是
纯熟是蓝
第一个是在大多数的
各位记住一句话
你可以会
然后再告诉你的好消息
这个事实上
特别辣的人特别多
然后给自己填标
却不愿意爬着的人特别多
所以只要你记住这句话
我可以会
你的生活就无限光明
这是第一个
第二个
提用价值这个事
分了两种
简单来说
一种就是通过体力帮人解决
占用时间的
一种是什么呢
把它变成
可复用的东西
我不推荐大家
用时间
因为时间是有限的
所以最后来做的
作出产品
这个我反正服务是过很多变的
所以这个又是一个常天
但是
做我常天做做什么
做产品
很多人会犯错我
我们很多老伙企最近
再做产品
然后那一无视频会的时候
我运了了很多这样的问题
今天中午
跟我们老伙
其实聊天的时候
然后我发现又一早的这个问题
然后我特意听他两次
我发现了
还是没反过来
我就再说一遍
我们很多人在做产品的时候
两个不好的习惯
第一个是什么呢
就是喜欢做很多功能
很多做很多功能
第二个是什么呢
喜欢自己去做设计
我一定要在乌里
我好设计
我不明说一句就认识
我好好设计
我先说第一个
第一个观点
各位
你理解的世界和真实的世界
之间有一个巨大的断层
但你不知知
二十二五年
只要讲大学做的个谁
就是
就是什么呢
就问你个问题
你了解自行车的工作原理吗
你知道达料是怎么回事吗
哈哈哈
好的
知道
打分七分八分
买分十分啊
结果
给他一张试
请你把自行车的工作原理化出来
请你把达料的工作原理化出来
选啥样的
就好准看穿一下
就看得挺黄
我要是回到过去
各位
你回到过去还是个飞舞
你你对自己不是很了解
我们理解的世界
和真实的世界
之间有一个断层
然后你在务力
你说我做一个很好
很好的设计对不起
你的那个设计
不行的
不终于我呢
我举个最简单的意思
就是你那个单级版
能夹那个时候获联网
你那个机器都没连网
你你
过期有一件事就
闭关苏国
说他就是你
所以第一个
不要仔细在乎你应别
你一定要是接出市场
第二个我们很人发的错误
人们就一上来就喜欢做一个特别
大功能就多了
我明白大家的心理
就是我会这么多东西
你挑一样
中央满足理
我讲个好事吧
就是原来我
当时在体道工作的时候
我们那个对面了
开了小面铺
那个小面铺上面贴的舅碼
南北
大赛满了
安全席
这小面铺的一边
也就百三四长所的
你说招笑不招笑吧
对不对
我们觉得很招笑
我们很多人就翻这个错误
明明一个小不大点的事
你非要把里面终一对动力
就和那个写的满美大赛满
很全体是一样的
你的想法是总有一样
符合你
任何一个笨蛋
都可以在现有的产品上天价功能
但是减少功能需要智慧
所以
各位体会一下吧
不你不需要更多的功能
那么具体该怎么做呢
我给大家具体实测的方法
给大家演示一下
上个礼拜来吧
我给我们的社群加了一个
AI主手叫江小湖
我只提供了一个功能
就是回答的问题
为什么
首先什么是知识
知识是问题的负产品
没有问题
知识就是垃圾
就是一点垃圾
一个白售没有用的
所以知识是问题的负产品
这是第一个
第二个问题
也是对关键的
原本为什么加入你的社群
只有一个原因
就是解决问题
对吧
它不是来学知识的
它不是因为你找的出来是来的
它经济社群的原因只有一个
就是一个问题
对吧
所以我们不需要停下那么多功能
我不是没能力
AI出现了刚刚更好做了
对吧
但是只做一个功能
看到哪个位
还是那个邏輯
认和一个本账
都可以忘记一下这个场面上
天下功能
但是
减少我们需要智慧
就说了半天就告诉你
我是一个很有智慧的人
但是你们知道吗
我是回答问题
这个选择特别好
好在哪儿
还记得吗
怎么还能赚到钱
发现问题解决问题
大家有问题问你
我现在处理方法是这样的
就是把我的知识故
比如说我以前直经求的
我的小包同的
我的输的
我的知识故全开放出来
大家问的问题
命中
对吧
当然是AI语意的
命中
命中的时候就不带回来
但是如果一个东西特别有深度的话
特别麻烦的话
那我就要手动过了
过完了以后
我要把这件那种猜放成
更小的原子
存回到我的知识故里的问题
各位就一道问题解决
问题解决
慢慢就可以同技出
人们遇到的最多的问题是什么
人们最关键的问题是什么
那么知道这个东西有什么用呢
撒些问题解决问题
就能转道歉
然后你就知道
第二个功能是什么了
然后你会发现
当你这很厉害功能是什么的时候
就很神奇的事情是什么呢
有些时候
你不知道你要做什么
就是你原来认为你
说做这个的
但是你做的做的说成那个的
久了一早
大家现在都你们可能没用过
叫认识
你们知道
这个可能我在国外很过
叫认识这么一个产品
他最开始是一款
毕竟位置的打卡认题
做这个这个打卡的结果就变成了
因此因此火了
以前那个美国
还有一款产品叫斯拉特
你们用过吗
所以他还是是游戏的
是做游戏用的
后来把它做成了
本工的
还有一款产品叫推特
这家公司是做不合恶的
都快死了了
做了的东西之后来的叫过了
所以很多产品
他不是一开始就定的
其实是你在做的做的过程中
然后你会发现是一眼
画出来的没有人知道
他会演画成什么样子
各位
所以你还认为产品是一开始
就这么做出来的吗
我门说一个很实在的例子
我门是去年
七反是八月份的
我们老婆就说
胡德哥,我们分享一下吧
就是讲了一下
怎么做短的平衡吗
都到过去想做短的平衡
我在说一遍
我分享是
我们现在分享的是
免费的
我不受课程是课示
我们是AA值的
当然只先用我们老婆去
对吧
然后很多人说
我去参加了胡德哥
什么什么都要多少钱
那是他的猜率费
这个要说一下
我看完了好
但是我花了多少钱
就参加胡德哥的
这个说一下
我讲课是不要钱的
我们分享是不要钱的
那个都是猜率费
然后呢
我们在分享的过程
因为很多老婆
就是说他没来不了
因为现场只能量100人
我就想
能不能把现场的东西
把它放到网络上
放到网络上的时候
我突然又想做个小实验吧
就是看看有多少人很奇怪
然后呢
收个小费用
叫实验来猫丝
为什么不是
为什么不是过9块9
因为我觉得9块9
代表的只是过9财的
实验来猫丝告诉我是个城鲜
发射器
结果当天
晚上就两千多人
两千多人
然后慢慢慢慢现在已经
把现场的
接近百钱
不得把现场的
对吧
他比开始不是规划出来的
他是长出来的
对吧
他长出来的
包括价格价格价格价格
包断大阻局的
这样一把什么
原来是我們的社群
我是把内容放在飞书上的
是不放在我们的行求 Menu
是放在飞书上的
大家都有什么问题
我就写
就写一片文章发出去
写一片文章发射去
大家闹到问题
在下面就留言
看不懂
拿禁什么都与你赶
然后慢慢尝尝
有一把现场в
东西特别好
又尝试一下
我就把它发到
攻往上看
部分
你们可以看1 2年
我会有闻闷的那个视频
其实就是获得大人的反馈
我就知道 人们的需求是什么
人们关心什么
所以我就写了三部分
第一部分是如何写习
第二部分是如何做
如何做是包括了如何创意
如何创意啊
如何做产品啊
第三个就是偷则
对吧
为什么 因为这本书实让是
等于用户的需求写出来
那我可以写别的 当然可写别的
我跟大家讲 我这本书至少是
至少是杀了三个人之一
就很
就是我自己来来回个改了三遍
还包含改了三遍
同时还把书杀了三人之一
明天我们见我的途中编辑
然后途中编辑告诉我
我们的书是少有的发行了几年之后
然后不断一刷了
不断一刷了
那好的那说
有人说我买蒙文的书那个书火的
都断火了 我跟你讲
如果一个书真的是唱笑的话
它不可能断火
它不赚钱吗
所以我到现在位置一直在印刷
就在印刷 为什么
就是因为它是从用户那长出来的
好 对总结一下
普通人
转钱最简单
最不可能反识
这个很重要的
你好多很多轻转的
整个钱也不是给谁给谁扔的
第二个是最常最持久的
转钱持久这人生嘛
是吧
但是我现在也的嘛
对吧
方法就是给别人提供价值
最简单的方法
就是发现问题解决法问题
只要你可能发现只要你分解决
你就能转到钱
因为很难的
很难不愿意动一样
很难给自己挑的标权
说我这个笨大我啥都不会
你可以回
然后最好的提供
解决方案的方法是什么
不是说提供提定
因为这件事情是有限的
是把它总产品
而产品
不是打而权
最好是从最少的功能
来做起
任何一个笨蛋都可以贴大功能
但是更少的功能需要智慧
而且不要一声来就想好了我
这个东西该怎么做
我的设计设计完全推广
不是这样的
产品不是想出来的
是一样的话出来的